so to anyone who watched my rant on
Annoying moviegoers first off thank you
very much but you know that I tried to
see a dead man down the other day didn't
really work out because of horrible
unforeseen circumstances so later that
day I decided to go to a different
theatre and see it again and guess what
everyone who was quiet it was amazing
and just dead man down is from the
director of the original Girl with the
Dragon Tattoo and stars Colin Farrell
and Noomi Rapace also in the original
Girl with the Dragon Tattoo this movie
is a movie that the trailers don't
really tell you the things that are
going on behind this movie the trailers
kind of give you a quick little idea of
what's going on but really there's a lot
of other layers to this movie and I'm
not gonna tell you much about the plot
of this movie because that way if you do
see the film you can experience it for
yourself
Colin Farrell works for this sort of
small-time mob run by Terrence Howard
now these guys go around taking care of
business
newbies character was in a very bad car
accident a few years ago and her entire
right side of her face had to be
reconstructed in certain ways she used
to be a beautician so this is really
hard for her because Beauty was a huge
part of her life and now she doesn't
look as good as she used to when she
finds out that Colin Farrell is involved
in this type of work she tries to
blackmail him now I probably just told
you about 10% of the plot of this movie
there is a whole bunch of other things
going on under the lines that I'm not
going to mention because I want you to
be able to experience this film because
I really enjoyed it I looked at some of
the reviews for this movie and I'm
honestly baffled by them because they
got very mixed reviews and a lot of
people said the movie was like overly
serious and had a lot of convoluted plot
twists I don't really get it really well
acted especially by Colin Farrell he was
great in this movie and knew Mira Paz
was also really good she has such a sexy
voice and she was great in this film too
they both really added a lot to their
characters the way this film was
directed it looks beautiful the city
escapes at night very Michael managed a
lot of time was taken with the direction
the characters sometimes sit back and
think about things before they say and
you can actually see them thinking about
it it's not like this quick cut
Hollywood thing that you're just given
and a lot of movies nowadays and I like
that about Deadman down I also like the
chemistry between these two characters
how their relationship grew and the
places it took them and I really liked
the different story twists that this
film took
I was not expecting a lot of them and I
found myself sitting there going Oh a
lot and a lot of people I saw were
complaining that they felt that the
story twists were a little unrealistic
and kind of preposterous and that's
perfectly fine if that's their opinion
but I just don't feel that way as the
movie was progressing there were certain
things that kept happening that I was
like what what does that mean I was
thinking that was kind of poorly done I
don't really get what that meant but as
more answers were given to me I was
sitting in my seat thinking oh that
thing that happened 20 minutes ago
that was the it was one of those movies
like that where it had a lot of mystery
to it and as you continue to watch the
movie certain answers are thrown your
way and it made me enjoy the experience
more as an audience member not to have
everything spoon-fed to me and I found
myself really engrossed in these
characters lives and the story Terrence
Howard was also really good in this
movie too this is one of the best
performances I've seen from him in a
long time I thought all the actors were
really good in this movie F Murray
Abraham is also in the film and he does
a good job a few of the complaints I do
have with the movie is the musical score
for the most part it's really good but
then there were times in the movie where
it's extremely overbearing and it feels
like it actually encroaches upon the
scene and it's like the musical score is
trying to tell you how to feel when it
shouldn't really be that huge to be more
subtle also during the first like half
hour of the film it was very totally
inconsistent and I found it to be a
little bit rocky but then once the plot
really kicked into full drive I found
that the tone remained very consistent
but all in all I really enjoyed deadman
town and I was surprised by this movie
I'm gonna give it a B+ so if you guys
check it out let me know what you
thought of the movie below thanks a lot
for watching and as always if you liked
this you can click right here and get
stuck mine eyes